as we venture into episode 3 surely
nothing Supernatural is going on right
your mother says hello she's waiting for
you uh-oh it's no magic right there's an
there's a real explanation for this I
sure hope there is and in this video
that's exactly what I plan to do we'll
work together at figuring out who's
behind these killings these Supernatural
occurrences and most terrifying of all
did Peter actually sleep with Liz no I
have theories for all of these and more
and be sure to stick around to the very
end as I'll be going over the trailers
for extra Clues on what we could be
seeing next but before we begin make
sure to like And subscribe and leave
your theories on what you think is
happening in the comments below it's
pretty deliberate that the opening shot
is of the silver sky mine in my previous
videos I've argued that the mine is
likely the source of all the strange
events going on in NIS we know that it's
been responsible for the black water
coming out of the Taps and its presence
may be linked to the increase of still
Birds it's not a coincidence then that
the episode begins with a birth one that
almost turns Grim as the child comes out
unable to breathe it makes me wonder
whether this near fatal birth is linked
to the mind this flashback seven years
ago seen evangelene Navaro when she
worked for the APF before she was
transferred to state troopers in fact
we'll get to learn the specific case
which caused this Rift between Liz and
Navaro a man by the name of William
wheeler shot and killed his girlfriend
Navaro and Liz knew that he was a Serial
abuser but couldn't legally do anything
to stop it and thus Navaro feels guilty
that she didn't do enough to protect
this poor woman perhaps this is why Liz
says she has compulsion to protect women
Nar was obsessed with the case she's got
this thing about women who get hurt one
of the women at the birthing center says
what's that doing here so Navaro
isn't liked amongst the community and
it's no wonder she's come to arrest any
kot talk for trespassing and destruction
of private property at the silver sky
mine it must be a difficult position for
Nar to be in on the one hand her people
seem to be more or less against the mine
while she works to protect the M's
interests by being a member of the
police force we're now 5 days into
ennis's constant night Hank has rallied
a bunch of his Hunter friends to search
for Raymond Clark the number one suspect
in the deaths of the salal scientists
Hank doesn't really seem to care if
Raymond is killed in this process hey
you want him
alive do we I've long suspected that
Hank has some sort of connection with
Annie that is yet to be revealed he
didn't want to give up her case files
which were conveniently stored in his
home he didn't disclose information that
Annie had visited salal prior to her
murder and because Raymond and Annie
were close it's possible Raymond knows
something about Annie and Hank that
would incriminate him hence why Hank
doesn't really care if Raymond is found
dead now did anyone else think it was
strange that the camera focused on these
oranges a hunter dropped some and Navaro
will pick one up and orange is about the
exact opposite of something you'd see up
in the tundra one can also be be seen
briefly in the opening credits so expect
these to have some sort of significance
in the episodes ahead Liz is pissed that
Hank has assembled a civilian mob to
take down Raymond something you probably
won't find in the police rule book but
given that this is Alaska everyone seems
to play fast and loose with the rules
for example Liz gets a vet to examine
the corpsicle even half joking if he'd
be able to do a postmortem on the bodies
Liz fakes a conversation with Oliver
Tock in order to break into his home Liz
will do what it takes to get the job
done even if it means bending the rules
Navaro seems to be more by the book I
mean just look at her reaction when she
finds out Liz is going to break into
this dude's home at the station Liz lies
to Peter about what actually happened
with William wheeler she says they're
both dead when we got there but in our
flashback we see that he's still alive
what if Liz or Navaro shot William right
there and the two covered it up to make
it look like a murder suicide it's a
murder suicide then there's this weird
whistling
tune
[Music]
whistling isn't something new that evil
characters have done in True Detective
in season 1 arrol chis would often
whistle although a markedly different
tune my best guess is that this is a
tune made for the show as I tried
shazaming it and humming it to my
friends and family and none of them had
a clue where it was from so if you know
where it's from let us all know in the
comments there are over 19 boxes of
evidence associated with Raymond Clark
most of which come from his secret
trailer the big question regarding Annie
and Raymond is why keep their
relationship is secret the irony isn't
lost on Liz when they're confused why
someone would have a secret relationship
when both she and Navaro have secret
relationships of their own Liz with
Connelly and Navaro with cavic Raymond
and Annie seem like a happy couple so
why would Raymond if he is a murderer
want a killer Liz observes that one of
the photos isn't like the others it's
candid suggesting someone else else took
it someone else knew of Annie and
Raymond's relationship and it doesn't
take long to link the blue hair dye to
that of local hairdresser Susan for over
6 years Susan withheld information that
Annie met Raymond while she and her were
giving haircuts to the men at the
research station or at least that's what
Liz and Navaro originally thought after
Annie's death Susan let the police know
about her connection with salal but this
is the first Liz has ever heard of this
Susan told Hank but Hank never
documented it stating that it's not his
job to keep track of of who sleeps with
who in town this raises some serious red
flags for Hank in fact based on the
evidence we currently have Hank is my
leading suspect for who killed Annie we
know he kept Annie's files didn't
disclose Susan's information wanted
Annie's lover Raymond dead has a
propensity for violence sleeps around
like he said Susan did and is even
chummy with Kate mckitrick of the silver
sky M an enemy of Annie's and did anyone
else notice that when Kate talks to Hank
she calls him Henry hi Henry is that
just a mistake or is there something
more here I'm counting on you don't be
suspicious don't be suspicious Susan
tells Navaro that Raymond was fixated on
Annie's spiral tattoo a tattoo that came
to Annie in dreams last episode Rose
said the symbol is older than Enis
itself which gives it this mystical
quality if you want to know a little
more about this symbol and its
connection with season 1 make sure to
check out my episode 2 video Susan had
also been seeing one of the salal men
Oliver to Guk the station former
equipment manager there are no records
of this Oliver guy anywhere and Susan
says he's a guy that doesn't want to be
found a little bit suspicious on the car
ride back we learn how over half of en's
population works at the mine so a lot of
people would have a vested interest in
keeping this thing open a lot of people
would want an he dead if Hank hasn't
been suspicious enough one of the first
things he asks Pete down at the rink is
what's dver up to Pete asks his dad
about what happened between Liz and
Navaro those years ago you know you know
what happened there she won't tell me
this is pretty sneaky as Liz told him
what happened a few hours ago either
he's asking this because he didn't
believe lizz's side of the story and
he's trying to catch her in a lie or
he's seeing what his father will say
Hank responds no idea which seems like a
total lie keep this in mind when Liz
throws Hank's coffee in his face and
doesn't reprimand him after Hank makes
the not so subtle accusation that she
slept with Peter maybe I had to file a
report on you for playing Mrs Robinson
with my kid this of course being a
reference to Dustin Hoffman and Anne B's
characters in The Graduate in which an
older woman seduces a younger man this
Robinson you're trying to seduce me now
did they actually sleep together while
possible I don't think so remember that
Peter has lost his mother and Liz has
lost her son so I think the more likely
scenario is that they're each using each
other to fill these holes in their life
there's even this brief moment where Liz
touches his face to make sure he's okay
I just get way more of a motherson vibe
from them than anything sexual twice
this season Peter has chosen Liz over
being with his wife again you could take
this as being a sexual thing but I see
it more as a son being at the beck and
call of his mother so if this accusation
isn't true then why didn't Liz kick the
out of Hank or at least reprimand
him I think it's because Hank really
knows what happened in that wheeler case
that either Liz or Navaro shot wheeler
and Liz can't do to Hank because he
has something on her that's just my take
let me know what you think in the
comments turns out that forensic Tech
Liz requested isn't able to fly in due
to inclement weather so Peter suggests
he get his cousin a veterinarian to take
a look before the bodies are shipped off
to Anchorage this is Vincent and the big
piece of information he gives us is that
the bodies died before they froze the
most likely scenario is cardiac arrest
it's no coincidence he brings up Caribou
leaping off cliffs just like we saw in
episode 1 but I've seen caribou's I have
plain fright if there's someone who
knows the whereabouts of The elusive
Oliver it's Cav who knows some of the
more shady characters in town due to his
home brew business in exchange for this
information he simply wants to know
something about Navaro and this is hard
for her because she's so closed off she
tells him about her childhood one filled
with an abusive father and mentally ill
mother who ventured off one night and
was murdered this is likely why she
cares so much about protecting women and
join the force she doesn't want what
happened to her happening to others
continuing her rebellious streak Lee
Joins up with Sherry to attend an
anti-mine rally and there are three
really interesting things I want to
point out here first is the black water
likely taken from the Taps to show
people what the mine has done Liz will
see this for herself when she goes to
wash her hands the second bit of
information is that the town has just
had another still birth the key word
here being another the implication is
that the mine is the cause of this and
finally take a look at the picture of
these Caribou in the back check out the
eyes they kind of look like those burnt
corneas on the Frozen scientists and and
this weird glimmer we saw on Travis's in
episode 1 now did any of you happen to
notice that Liz is just listening to
static does she realize she's doing that
we've heard static sounds before on
Rose's radio before she sees Travis and
also in Navarro's car before she sees
the polar bear the static always seems
to precede something Supernatural now
did any of you clock this strange
clip it's almost as if she's noticing
something the static is still in the
background it's just all around
weirdness this is just before Lee comes
home and Liz demands she take off that
temporary tattoo I talked more about
lizz's contempt for indigenous culture
in my episode 2 video but she once again
demands that Lee remove this tattoo a
metaphor for the literal wiping out of
her culture all Lee really wants is for
Liz to care about what's going on in
town Liz doesn't seem too concerned
about the mine at least in comparison to
Lee and when push comes to shove Liz
will be called in to protect the mine
should any protests happen so you can
see a lot of potential for conflict here
upon leaving cic's fishing shack Navaro
experiences a vision of a small child
this is Liz's son Holden Danvers who we
can see here in the credits he's holding
the oneeyed polar bear plushy that Liz
found under her bed and again in this
box telling Navaro to quote get his
mommy when Navaro conks her head on the
ice she is transported to this Barren
land which looks a lot like the one from
her flashback in episode one Navaro used
to be in the military and this looks to
be some sort of destroyed Convoy my best
guests we're in Afghanistan besides
staving off a head injury Navaro has to
deal with her sister who's been
experiencing increasingly dangerous
bouts of mental illness jules's big
concern is that she'll wind up like her
mother who had similar problems the
scene taking place behind an abandoned
ship at Sea mimics Jewel's mental
illness and loneliness that feeling of
being distant from everyone else and
that seems to be a major theme of not
only this episode but the season what
are you doing when you're lonely Liz
attends what appears to be the Wake for
the still birth of that child the
situation makes her visibly hot and
uncomfortable having to take a moment in
the bathroom no doubt she must feel for
someone who has lost a child since she
lost one herself Liz and Navaro track
down Oliver at a nomad camp along the
North Shore and he isn't too pleased
when the cops come showing up at his
door entering without a warrant no less
there's this interesting back and forth
about him wanting to know Navarro's ANC
name oh you forgot did didn't you the
sad tragedy of it all is she never
learned it from her mother while this
guy probably thinks she's just turned
her back on her Heritage when he finds
out his former colleagues that salal
passed away he is visibly saddened
quickly turning to rage shoeing the
detectives out I personally think he
wasn't involved in the murders but with
him being in charge of the scientific
equipment I wouldn't be surprised if he
makes another appearance at the hospital
Dr Lun the Lone Survivor of the
corpsicle has regained Consciousness
having his legs and an arm amputated and
no longer being able to see he has a
chilling message for the detective
stating that we woke her she's awake
she's out there in the ice she came for
us in the dark the big question is who
is he talking about the first person
that comes to mind is Annie we'll see
her in this ice so to speak in the video
of the cavern on her phone but Annie's
dead making this all the more mysterious
maybe the she he is referring to is
something more out of the box referring
to something like the organisms found in
their samples or Mother Nature herself
again the questioner Rises can this be
explained with science or are we dealing
with something truly Supernatural and
while Liz goes to handle some Rowdy
Hunters Navaro is left alone and lond
has a spooky message for her your mother
says hello she's waiting for you to our
knowledge Navaro and Lund have never met
so how would he know about her mother I
don't think this happened I think this
was all in Navarro's head in episode 2
her mother does this weird pointing
gesture the same thing Lund will do here
remember that she just bonked her head
so she might not be thinking straight
plus she's had all sorts of Visions from
her military days to a oneeyed polar
bear we cannot take what she sees at
face value the episode ends with Peter
having unlocked and discovered a video
on Annie's phone here Annie explores
some sort of Ice Cavern stating
pH it's here whatever it is is likely
what got her killed as we'll hear her
screaming in pain this might be a bit of
a stretch but is this black outline here
forming a spiral or some other Dr crying
it's also important to note that Annie's
phone was found at the trailer not at
the bottom of some Ice Cavern so Annie
either escaped this encounter or it was
brought back up by someone else maybe
this was Raymond Clark but if it was
Raymond who murdered her then why leave
a phone that has evidence like this on
it this episode left us with far more
questions than it did answers but we
still have more to dive into Now we move
on to our trailer slothing section where
we take a look at the season's trailers
to see if there are any clues as to what
will happen next note that I won't be
going over every shot just the ones I
think are important to the story we
still have yet to see this shot of Liz
being interviewed it's similar to Rustin
Marty's interviews in season 1 so this
is either a case before the events of
the show or her being questioned after
we have this picture of someone wearing
Annie's jacket at the salal station I
wonder if this was a shot they were
going to use in episode one but thought
it was too much of a giveaway my guess
is that this is either Raymond Clark or
this guy Liz makes her way back to salal
station so something must be br bringing
her back here a spiral at this abandoned
Factory in this wide shot we'll see a
radio and campfire looks like someone
has been hanging out here someone with
that pink jacket that runs the top the
catwalk again is it Raymond or this guy
Navaro comes face to face with a wet
haired Jewels is this another one of
Navarro's Visions or has Jewels crept
out into the frozen tundra naked like
those scientists Lee smears black paint
over her face suggesting she continues
on with her protests at the mine Navaro
embracing Liz here by the fire it looks
like they've been through hell check out
Navaro here not in uniform inside what
appears to be the same cave Annie was in
in this other shot we see Navaro again
not in her uniform but this time at
salal could something happen that gets
Navaro kicked off the case or even Liz
for that matter as when we see her here
she's also not in her uniform we haven't
seen this shot of jwes really going
through some sort of psychotic break
this is what will likely Force Navaro to
put her in the hospital something she
promised she wouldn't do here's Lee
getting the kicked out of her at
the mine protest we'll later see that
Navaro is a riot officer here is this
part of her state trooper duties did she
get demoted or are we dealing with two
different protests one with Lee in
present day and one with Annie in the
past we do get the shot of Annie
haunting Navaro while she's in her riot
gear this is one of my favorite shots
last episode I theorized this is Peter
judging by his jacket and boots with the
body in the background here being that
of his father's a person perhaps Raymond
making his way down an ice tunnel here's
the dead woman from the wheeler case
pointing at someone likely Navaro since
both lond and her mother did the same
exact gesture this gesture is also seen
with this boy who may or may not be
lizz's son Holden Navaro and Liz whose
red coat you can see in the bottom right
here tie up maybe Raymond the same
person will see dragging Navaro across
the salal station in this shot of the
man tied up take a look at the glass on
the floor here it seems to match up with
Liz Breaking Free of the freezer at the
station remember that orange from
earlier in the episode it makes an
appearance to jwes Rolling under her bed
a pool of blood at lizz's home with
someone carrying a bunch of cleaning
supplies and it looks like Liz and
Navaro make their way to that Ice Cavern
where Annie's video was taken there's
still a lot more to get through as True
Detective has three more episodes left
and I hope you'll stick with me as we
get closer and closer to the end thanks
for watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and leave your thoughts and
theories about the show in the comments
below for more bad takes you can follow
me on Twitter and Instagram @ thinkstory
YT until next time remember Daddy loves
you very
much